hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a drama Thriller film called
Papillon spoilers ahead watch out ants
take care
[Music]
1931 Henry cherriere AKA Papillon is a
professional safe cracker from Paris his
usual day consists of breaking into
Mansions stealing expensive jewelry and
handing it over to his boss in return he
gets paid handsomely one day after a
successful Heist he meets his boss and
hands him over the diamonds that he just
stole the latter inquires if he kept
some of the diamonds for himself but
Papillon declines the boss then brings
forth a badly beaten up man and explains
that anyone who lies to him will suffer
the same consequence does he just keep
that guy there at all times to threaten
people randomly thanks Papillon Papillon
is obviously intimidated by the site but
he keeps his cool and leaves with the
payment shortly after he meets his
girlfriend Nanette and offers her some
jewelry that he had concealed from his
boss badass as they walk away a man
notices them in particular the necklace
that Nanette is holding that night the
couple makes love and discusses their
future Nanette wants to settle in the
countryside far from the world of crime
but Papillon thinks that they won't earn
enough there I was made to milk the rich
not cows the next morning as the two
continue their discussion a sudden knock
is heard on the door as soon as Papillon
opens it a bunch of cops apprehend him
he is being framed for the murder of the
same person his boss had beaten up last
night Papillon tries to explain that he
was with his girlfriend the entire night
but the officers ignore his pleas and
take him away later at the police
station Papillon is visited by nanat who
asserts that she wants to give a
testimony however he stops her saying
it'll be of no use Papillon knows that
no matter what he does the police aren't
going to let him go so instead he plans
on breaking out of the prison before
leaving Papillon tells his girlfriend to
move on with her life but she refuses
after Nanette leaves Papillon befriends
a fellow inmate named julot who reveals
that in order to break out of a prison
one needs a lot of money he then points
at a seemingly harmless man named Louis
dega and says he is the solution
apparently dega is a millionaire who has
been arrested on the charges of
counterfeiting money even now he has
hidden a lot of cash inside the place
where the Sun never shines what's with
prison movies and putting ass in cash I
mean cash and you know what I mean
meanwhile all the prisoners are being
taken to the penal colony in French
Guiana by boat at night Papillon
approaches dega and offers some
protection in exchange for money but the
latter refuses further at night as all
the prisoners are resting dega notices
the guy next to him being brutally
murdered it turns out he had hidden
money inside his stomach and that's why
he had become a Target Vega is
terrorized by the incident so the very
next morning he approaches Papillon and
accepts the offer the deal is that dega
will be given protection until he
reaches the penal colony he doesn't want
to escape with Papillon as he believes
his wife will soon get him out later
while everyone is resting the same
murderer from last night targets dega he
slowly proceeds to strike his victim but
this time Papillon comes to the rescue
the two engage in a fight which alerts
the officers Papillon is punished but he
doesn't seem to care he is just happy
that dega wasn't killed the next morning
the boat finally arrives at the penal
colony before everyone can proceed
Juliet purposely injures himself so that
he can be taken to the infirmary his
plan is to escape from there as the
infirmary is the least guarded after a
while Papillon and the others finally
reached the colony where they will be
imprisoned the place is full of deadly
criminals many of whom have been charged
for murder the warden is also a cruel
man he gathers all the new inmates and
reveals that escaping the place is
impossible if someone is caught they
will be sent to solitary confinement for
two years if they are caught for the
second time solitary confinement for
three years and if they are caught
escaping for the third time they will be
sent to the notorious Devil's Island a
place where people go insane the warden
also explains that if anyone commits a
murder they will be publicly decapitated
in a guillotine in the next scene all
the inmates are assigned to collect
rocks while Papillon does it efficiently
dega is struggling to keep up because he
is not used to labor later Papillon
meets a boat man and offers him a large
amount of cash in in exchange for a boat
the man agrees and he tells Papillon to
arrive at the shore the following night
just then a dangerous looking inmate
finds out about the plan and approaches
dega to take his money but even this
time Papillon arrives to the rescue he
fights with the man and defeats him
although he gets hurt in the process
seeing this dega realizes that he won't
be able to last a single day without
Papillon by the time his wife finds a
solution to get him out he will be his
long dead hence with no options left
dega also joins Papillon in his Escape
Plan the next morning all the prisoners
are summoned to the yard to witness an
execution it turns out that while trying
to escape julot killed two guards hence
now he is going to be punished in a
guillotine as the prisoners watch in
horror julad is fitted to the device and
castrated I mean decapitated the warden
then orders Papillon and Daga to take
the corpse to the burial site
unfortunately along the way dega breaks
down he had never even seen a dead body
in his life but now he is being made to
carry a headless man papion encourages
him to get up but to no avail just then
the guards also arrive and threaten dega
to pick up the corpse when he refuses
one of them starts whipping him in the
back Papillon cannot bear it anymore so
in a fit of rage he picks up a rock and
smashes the guard's head with it he then
makes a run for it but poor dega cannot
move an inch due to fear at night
Papillon arrives at the shore and meets
the boat man he requests for the boat
but to his surprise the man starts
laughing when Papillon turns around he
notices several guards it turns out The
Boatman had already informed the warden
about the Escape he gets a good sum of
money every time he provides information
about an inmate who is attempting to
escape shortly after Papillon is brought
back to the prison and the warden gives
him some good news the guard he struck
earlier is still alive and this means
that papion won't be given a death
punishment instead he will be sent to
solitary confinement on another Island
when he arrives he finds the place
desolate and gloomy there is only one
rule don't make any noise in the
previous prison inmates could roam
around and chat with their friends but
in this one they are confined to a small
room even talking to oneself is a
punishable offense here moreover the
food is inadequate and bad Papillon is
only given a single Meal which is a
strange looking soup but one day
surprisingly he receives a coconut
inside there is a note that mentions he
will get coconuts every day from now on
realizing that it's from Daga Papillon
eats the meal happily this goes on for a
few weeks but the warden eventually
finds out and kills the guard who is
serving the food then he confronts
Papillon and asks him who's responsible
for it as expected the latter doesn't
reveal anything as a punishment the
warden cuts his already inadequate
ration in half a month passes by
Papillon has become very weak due to the
lack of nutrients in his body the warden
again approaches him with a delicious
meal in his hand and inquires who sent
him the coconuts but just like the last
time Papillon remains silent enraged the
warden decides to leave him in the
darkness for the remainder of his
sentence now Papillon is left in a
terrifying situation he doesn't get
proper food he has no one to talk to and
he cannot even see his surroundings
slowly the tranquility and lack of
proper food starts making him insane
Papillon becomes so weak that he is
unable to move hence he is taken to the
prison hospital coincidentally Daga has
started working at the same place in the
past year and a half he won the warden's
trust because of which he has given
Extra Protection and privileges one day
Daga meets his friend and learns that he
is only pretending to be insane Papillon
knew that this is the only way to return
back to the prison so he started acting
like a maniac that's nothing says dega I
once thought I was Freddie Mercury then
the duo again starts discussing their
escape plan this time they choose two
more prisoners as Helping Hands Papillon
wants someone who is strong and cunning
while [ __ ] wants to help someone who is
often exploited they end up recruiting a
brute named Celia and a guy who is
always bullied matsurat following this
dega gives all of his savings to celier
and the latter uses his connections to
buy a boat have they learned nothing the
following night a movie is going to be
shown and that is when the quartet plans
to escape dega is nervous about the
whole thing and at one point he even
considers backing out however his best
friend Papillon makes him understand
that this is their one and only shot at
Freedom it is now or never in the next
scene we are taken to the movie night
several officials have arrived and dega
is seen serving them drinks as per the
plan he spikes them with narcotics and
waits for the perfect moment to steal
the keys to the main gate inside
Papillon and the others are waiting for
dega to return When suddenly it starts
raining this causes the power to go out
scared celier suggests they make a run
for it and find an alternate route but
Papillon refuses he is not going to
leave without his friend fortunately
Daga arrives in the nick of time with
the keys taking advantage of the
darkness the group opens the main door
and quickly flees the prison after a
while they reach a dead end the only way
to reach the shore is by jumping
Papillon celier and matarat land
successfully but when it's Degas Turn
the Lights suddenly come back on this
startles him causing him to land
awkwardly and break his leg now that he
is unable to walk celier suggests they
leave him behind but Papillon once again
refuses he along with matarat carry the
wounded Daga and eventually reach the
shore where a boat is waiting for them
wasting no time the four hop in and sail
away into the darkness of the ocean the
next morning it has been hours since
their escape but Celia notes that they
haven't reached very far this is because
the boat is very small and it cannot
hold the way to four people just then
they see a storm approaching their way
realizing that they have very little
time Celia Chucks matarat into the ocean
and then goes after dega however
Papillon gets in the way resulting in a
brutal fight celier being the larger man
gains the upper hand and is about to
kill Papillon when suddenly dega stabs
him from behind the duo then throws him
off the boat and helps matarat climb
back up after a while the huge storm
engulfs them and the screen Fades to
Black when they wake up they find
themselves on an island it turns out a
nearby community saw them floating in
the ocean and rescued them as Papillon
roams around the place in confusion a
nun greets them and reveals that they
are in Colombia she also mentions that
she knows what they did and where they
came from Papillon tries explaining
himself but the nun says that he is safe
as long as he repents for his sins that
evening Papillon meets his best friend
and tells him that they should leave the
place immediately however dagger refuses
saying that their deal is over he is
tired of running and now wants to stay
in one place forever and what better
place to stay than the island right next
to the prison they just escaped Papillon
leaves him and heads to matarat but he
too has become accustomed to the place
especially the girls hence Papillon
decides to leave the place alone but as
he nears the boat he notices a couple of
officers pulling up it turns out the
evil nun gave up their look at the evil
nun gave up their location to the
authorities alarmed Papillon quickly
returns to Daga and helps him up but by
this time the officers have already
noticed them matter at his shot and
killed on the Spot while Papillon and
Daga are apprehended and once again
taken back to prison cut to five years
later Papillon has finished his sentence
in solitary confinement and he is now
being taken to Devil's Island to his
shock he finds dega there it is revealed
that he got a harsher punishment because
he spiked the drinks of the officers
dega was brought to Devil's Island right
after he came back from Colombia the two
are excited to reunite after five long
years they may have become old but the
friendship and bond they had Remains the
Same that evening when Papillon stares
into the ocean an idea suddenly strikes
his mind he approaches dega and tells
him that if they can make a small raft
the waves will take them to the nearest
shore however this time dagger refuses
to be a part of it he explains that for
five years he has lived a peaceful life
without any trouble or violence he has
also learned that his wife has married
someone else so there is no point in
going back speak for yourself says
Papillon I'm a goddamn himbo I'll get us
both new wives in 20 seconds nonetheless
he decides to assist Papillon in making
the raft out of coconuts the next
morning the two friends hug each other
and say their goodbyes then Papillon
throws the raft into the ocean before
jumping in himself the plan works and
the waves appear to be taking him
somewhere as he floats away dega has
tears in his eyes in the final scene we
are taken to the year 1967. Papillon now
lives in Venezuela as he is still a
wanted criminal in France but in 1969 he
is pardoned of all his crimes Papillon
has written A Memoir of all the events
which he now plans to publish he will
title it that time I went cocoa nuts the
movie ends as he travels to Paris for
the first time in 38 long years
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching